on vient parler avec une des
psychologues qui a travaillé à la
conception du jeu fort net un jeu très
populaire qui également visé depuis la
fin de la semaine par une demande
d'actions collectives parce qu'on dit
qu'il créerait une dépendance chez les
joueurs et que ça aurait été conçu
vraiment volontairement de cette façon
là avec moi ce matin maître
jean-philippe caron qui est l'un des
avocats derrière cette demande d'actions
collectives bonjour m car on vous
remercie pour ça vous remercie d'être là
également et stéphanie harvey alias miss
arue et donc joueuse professionnelle
tout d'abord vous avez entendu donc
cette entrevue lors comment vous
réagissez à l'entrevue avec la
psychologue mais moi je ne peux pas
commenter publiquement l'entrevue
convient d'entendre pour la simple et
unique raison que les doigts aussi
devant les tribunaux et que cette
personne n'a rien dit et - clic on va on
d'avoir interrogé plus tard dans le
processus
donc je mets tous tenir à ce moment un
studio quelconque commentaire
lot-et-garonne ce qui vient d'être dit
depuis la publication de votre demande
d'action collective est ce que vous avez
reçu des communications de la part de
deux parents qui sont touchées par la
problématique
oui on a eu extrêmement de commentaires
à près de 250 commentaires qui ont été
envoyés à travers notre site web
elle est partout au canada et en europe
250 way 250 avec des histoires qui sont
assez troublante
on va pouvoir revenir dans les
prochaines semaines on va rencontrer
toutes les personnes qui nous ont
contactés j'ai passé j'en ai profité de
la tribune que vous m'offrez aujourd'hui
également si des gens la maison qu'ils
ont vécu des situations de dépendance
notamment par les services qui sont
offerts par les grands chemins on vous
invite fortement entre en contact avec
nous à travers notre site web au qu'alex
boutiques.com dans la section action
collective pour nous transmettre vos
coordonnées votre histoire
on veut parler on veut vous rencontrez
on veut savoir on va aller au fond des
choses par rapport à cette situation
vous êtes déterminés à aller plus loin
par rapport à tout ça donc on va voir
entre autres si l'action un collectif
sera autorisée par les tribunaux ça
c'est la première étape et stéphane
hervé comment vous réagissez à tous à
vous ce matin moi j'ai beaucoup plus de
questions que de gérer des commentaires
sauf que moi en lisant ce que j'ai vu
dans les journaux
en fait c'est pour ça que j'ai un peu
contente d'être ici parce que je suis
assis à côté m
à côté la personne qui s'en occupe mais
il y avait beaucoup de problématiques
qui semblait intéressante qui semblait
quelque chose que je parle souvent dans
les médias ce qui veut dire la
responsabilité par rapport à ce qui se
passe sur internet au niveau que je
souhaite du gouvernement qui a pas
vraiment de règle présentement que sa
peluche plus fort que les jeux peuvent
faire un peu ce qu'ils veulent mais dans
l'autre sens y avait beaucoup de
déresponsabilisation et de l'éducation
parentale qui semblait très très étrange
donc des choses comme élise des enfants
en mode présent qui jouent au jeu alors
que le jeu est clairement écrit comme un
jeu très influent donc t il ya quand
même beaucoup de questionnements par
rapport à cette situation
puis nous résumer un peu pour ceux qui
connaissent moins fort natoli en coin
s'est pas adapté à votre avis aux plus
jeunes aux moins de 13 ans mais c'est
sûr que c'est un jeu qui est dit pour
les petits mots pour les adolescents et
plus dont 13 ans u ça ça veut dire que
si le parent décide de laisser un enfant
de moins de 13 ans a joué à ce jeu c'est
sûr qu'il ya plus de risques que ça soit
problématique et ont su de ça on en a
mentionné un peu le lait est un peu
loupé blocks comme on dit dans le terme
du game design et les bois de laiteries
qui est en jeu il faut connaître le
retirer du jeu depuis 2010 neuf donc ce
n'est plus dans le jeu et moi je pense
que c'est un problème qui est
intéressant un problème qu'on doit
s'attaquer enfin fils et moi en tout cas
ça veut dire que ça reprend un peu comme
la laiterie concerné loterie vidéo
on sait pas trop ce contenu
d'abord la prochaine aussi j'ai fait ça
c'est un problème mais est ce que ça
vous démontre le besoin de poursuivre
son rythme est de faire un recours
collectif là dessus moi je pense que
l'on s'attaque pas la bonne personne c
ur de dresser papier la législation de
tout ça aux règles qu'on a un pack
société du fait que justement on se met
la tête dans le sable responsabilité
c'est ce que vous dites donc aux blancs
autant le gouvernement que les
concepteurs de jeux oublier également
les parents aussi émettre qu'à renvoyer
soit différemment goodwill bien sûr mais
j'y allais un petit peu d'expérience
qu'on a vécu depuis hier on a fait
énormément notre vie sur le sujet pions
il y avait deux constantes y avait les
personnes qui avaient eu la chance de
lire là devant les sous qu'il ait pas eu
la chance de lire la demande
j'invite tout le monde à la maison il
est disponible sur notre site internet
la demande d'en prendre connaissance et
à ses deux filles fait 37 pages qui
peut-être que vous allez mieux
comprendre les bases juridiques et
génomique avait personne
grosso modo c'est plus le devoir
d'information d'un fabricant de produits
qu'on attaque à savoir qu'on a
l'obligation dans notre société de
divulguer les risques inhérents
l'utilisation d'un produit qu'il est si
l'arrêté en qu'est ce qui s'est passé
dans l'action collective sur le tableau
des bus et qu'est ce qui s'est passé par
la suite dans le fond vous vous dites
que si avant on a voulu rendre les
joueurs dépendantes jeu exactement on
veut passer on a bâti un produit dans le
but que l'utilisateur soit à dicter
accroché au jeu particulièrement au
niveau des enfants je trouve ça
intéressant qu'est ce que vous avez dit
par rapport au public cible puisqu'il ya
une station on en a demandé trop docile
d'instance dans le volet public taux
d'enfants de moins de 13 ans qui te
commentaires de la psychologue que vous
avez eu tout à l'heure par rapport à
commettre le jeu a été créé pour viser
les jeunes garçons en brasage avec les
couleurs les recourants le monde pas de
violence parce que c'est quelque chose
qui est très intéressant analyse et puis
honnêtement j'invite les gens à prendre
connaissance peut-être que votre vision
de la chose doit changer après avoir lu
les allégations parce que nous bien
honnêtement ça fait quelques semaines
qu'on travaille sur ce dossier là puis
on été profondément touché troubler la
santé de santé publique liés à la
dépendance
des jeux vidéo est-ce que vous allez
mettez quand même que les jeux vidéo
vont où vont trop loin
moi encore une fois je pense pas que les
jeux vidéos qui vont trop loin je pense
que c'est le la non réglementation est
présentement j'ai du temps qu'internet
c'est le far-west ok on ne peut pas
vraiment de réglementation que ce soit
pour la cyberintimidation la
cyberdépendance et le support aux
parents le support aux professeurs aux
écoles et on est en danger dirait en bon
d'anglicismes denial cueilli un problème
avec lui en digne exact qu'un problème
est ce que dans le cas du recours
collectif les 250 personnes qui ont
contacté
comment ces sujets qu'ils ont compris
est-ce que les 250 étaient vraiment
victime de cyber dépendance faut savoir
que la super de pardon c'est une maladie
a été reconnue comme une maladie fait
plutôt que notre enfant j'ai trois
heures par jour qu'il est super
dépendance et cette fois ci il faut pas
penser
exact c'est très important qu'on en
parle aujourd'hui que c'est pas parce
qu'un enfant joue énormément à des jeux
vidéo qui les bars dépendants et killer
d'un problème c'est pas parce qu'on est
enfant consomme et un jeu vidéo qui sont
négatifs au contraire la plupart des
gens qui jouent à des jeux vidéo c'est
un univers qui est extrêmement positif
pour eux et c'est ça que j'ai peur avec
cette ex présentement ce qui se passe
dans les médias
comment on attaque le jeu alors qu'on
devrait attaquer pâteux sommes attaqués
mais qu'on ne devrait plus faire la
prévention est plutôt que de pointer du
doigt moi je dirais la est un jeu qui en
fait victime de l'industrie au conflit
et macarons vous vous dites on aide
aussi le lieu dont en terminant à la
définition de dépendance et pas nous
entends cabinet d'avocats déterminé ça
c'est une preuve d'experts qui va être
fait dans le cadre du procès attendu par
la définition du groupe pour mettre
antique et qu'est ce qu'une dépendance
aux jeux vidéo vont être faits en temps
et lieu comme mon affaire par rapport au
tabac le groupe de létourneau qui venu
déterminer combien de cigarettes doivent
être consommés par jour ça a été fait à
la suite de l'audition de la salle
collective donc est trop tôt aujourd'hui
c'est un hôtel on est au début du
processus faut pas confiance aux prises
pour ça il faut voir si les tribunaux
donneront leur feu vert à la demande
d'actions collectives que vous avez
réclamé m jean philippe caron merci
d'avoir été là
stéphane et hervé jaurès professionnels
merci vous bien fou merci